joining us right now is the author of
the best-selling book it's better to be
feared about the uh new england patriots
dynasty in the pursuit of greatness seth
wickersham back here on the rich island
show how are you seth
good man how are you i'm doing fine so
let's get uh first up about uh why you
think brady decided to finally hang them
up in your estimation
yeah i mean i don't think it's one
reason i do think that you can't
overlook the fact that football is
really hard and he's made it look so
easy for so long that it's kind of easy
to take for granted but it is really
hard to
play football
especially entering your 40s at a high
level nobody really knows except for him
what that's like and i think that he was
being honest when he referenced in his
statement today that
you know he didn't feel like he could
give that effort right he's always said
once you stop you're done and
but i do think there are some other
factors at play i mean
he loved the coaches in tampa bay but he
you know referenced it in a statement
today that he would drive bruce arians
crazy i mean sometimes the box coaches
weren't quite as buttoned up as things
were in new england and i think that you
know the way you saw the way they lost
that game to the rims isolating cooper
cup on a safety is an example of that
um you know they're a team in transition
and they're going to have some roster
and salary cap issues and then i think
that
more than anything you saw
him take steps this past year to be
known as more than just tom brady the
quarterback and really more than tom
brady the quarterback and
fitness guru i mean you saw he he
launched his podcast with jim gray and
larry fitzgerald he did man in the arena
um
and the brady brand i think that he that
it really seemed to energize him in a
way that
you know for the longest time i think
that only football could
and you know he sees a lot of global
potential with that especially with the
t v twelve
you know pairing it up with some of the
methodologies within tb12 all that said
this is a gigantic hole that he is
leaving in his life it's a void there's
a reason why he's
said in the past that he'll consider
therapy when he walks away because
as giselle has said football is his
first love and um as we know with with
great athletes when they walk away
the golf courses and the private jets
and
you know the cushy paid speeches get old
fast
yeah i know and it's just it's gonna be
weird for fans too because um i i
thought he could have kept playing you
know and um and obviously he didn't end
it
um with a win in the super bowl and i
always thought that you know tom brady
would absolutely add himself to the list
of peyton manning
and strahan and elway and betis right
that you know uh that that's the way
they did it you know ray ray lewis right
i mean like that's the way to do it
and he wouldn't want to even walk into
the bust room one day knowing he's got
the every possible record that others
have something that he doesn't you know
i i
i always kind of figure but you can't
control that
um with the exception of last year he
could have last year
yeah i think he's been a little bit
different like there was a moment that
i was at his i was in the living room
and we were talking this is maybe seven
years ago it was before the sort of
rest of the dynasty which not only the
patriots but really the tom brady
dynasty kind of
was reclamated and
he was telling me about they had just
lost to the ravens in the playoffs and
he told me that kurt warner had sent him
a text after the game saying like being
the best doesn't mean you always win it
just means you win more than anybody
else
and that text really meant a lot to him
because it it spoke to his essence in a
way that very few messages could it yes
it's always about winning but it was
often in failure that he found successes
and
you know the the people there's people
who argued he'd never leave new england
after throwing a pick six on his final
throw
against the titans and there's people
who'd argue he'd never go out losing to
the los angeles rams in the playoffs but
you know that was
it it always misread him just a little
bit
i think that what he prided himself on
as much as anything
is this kind of genius he had of
refusing to concede anyone else's idea
of the inevitable or of reality in that
regard espn senior writer and author of
the uh the book it's better to be feared
seth wickersham right here on the rich
eisen show what about the way it all
went down
for retiring that was weird there's no
other way to put it and normally that's
not a word that you associate with tom
brady when he can control something
right yeah so you know what was weird um
i think that those close to him
and you know people inside the box
started to see this coming maybe about a
month and a half ago
um we did like a playoff predictions
column on espn.com before the playoffs
and i predicted that brady would retire
after this year and it wasn't a report
it was a prediction but i just heard
enough
that
you know
i think that all of the
the strain from the game all the
opportunities beyond it it was just
starting to crystallize for him and
remember when he left doing when he
signed a two-year contract i know that
he renegotiated in the offseason and was
talking about playing until he's 55 but
a lot of that was like kind of for
salary cap purposes he signed a two-year
deal and i think that
you know the people close them were
always kind of looking at that as an end
date obviously he could change his mind
at any time but
so when he when when adam schefter and
jeff darlington a week ago reported that
he was non-committal towards returning
to the box i think that was a huge tell
and then obviously the report over the
weekend
came out and then got some fierce blow
back
but
you know i think that he was always
going to retire they always knew how
this was going to end
adam and jeff had to weather the storm
for their reporting to be validated and
um it's pretty obvious given that the
commissioner weighed in peyton manning
weighed in
that
today this morning was going to be the
morning that he was going to do it
well again i i i never you know um
doubted jeff and
schefter's reporting it was just
definitely not the manner in which
he he he wanted it out there right and
then the question is is just
you know even
last night you know having his own
podcast at his disposal
um and and then choosing this manner in
which to do it
um do you think this was the plan like
what was the plan best you could tell do
you think yeah i mean i think that it
was
you know given that other people have
had kind of come out and
and
you know congratulated him on his career
like payton like
you know robert craft like roger goodell
but that said i mean you know this
it was a messy process it really was and
um
but
you know i'm sure that like even jeff
and adam reporting it had to have been a
little surprised by the you know just
how stiff the blowback was i don't know
that for a fact i'm just guessing but
you know here we are and you know he
ended up doing it and um you know just
you run out of superlatives to say i
when he was first starting out
i figured who it was someone was close
to him was saying that like he wants to
have a career that makes you forget any
other quarterback and you know
like that's such a bold statement that i
never forgot it and at the time he
hadn't even won a second super bowl yet
and so this was at the time he looked
like another in a trend right like like
kurt warner and jake deloam and these
guys who kind of come out of nowhere and
end up having success
it he didn't look like anything that he
would become
and i'll never forget someone said that
and i just think it like always spoke to
his ambition and here we are all these
years later two decades later
and it really is his accomplishments are
so vast
and so far-reaching that it really is
kind of
it makes other guys who accomplish
phenomenal feats in the game look small
oh yeah i mean like from now on you got
to win four to be in the conversation
right
and you've got to be above four well you
got to be in four and four in terms of
the conversation of best you know um
second best ever right yeah and then and
then you've gotta pass that and then
you've gotta last as long as brady did
and look as great as brady did while
lasting as long as he did to even be
remotely in his arena to use his phrase
like that's it from now on and when we
were kids it was like you got two now
we're talking about getting you a boston
canton right like now two is just like
one quarter of the way there i mean it's
totally been reset
yeah last night was the anniversary of
um
the broncos super bowl win over the
falcons that was always final game and
he's scrambling around in that game
throwing 80 yard bombs for touchdowns
and you know he walked away with two
straight super bowl wins and five super
bowl appearances and the winningest
quarterback in nfl history and that just
looked like it was untouchable he looked
like he was walking away not maybe at
the top of his game but he maybe could
have kept going
and
hit the brady eclipse five super bowls a
long time ago
so uh just in that respect then um the
next step does he do what uh elway did
does he want to get in um you know
football
um
management does he want to own a team
clearly it seems like he's got his own
businesses that's what he wants to do
anything he wants to do in media anyone
will fall over themselves to get him so
you know what do you think next act
final for his next act yeah i mean i
think that for the immediate future i
think he's really going to try to take
his brand and tb12 and the brady brand
global and and see what the potential is
with that but that said
you know a lot of these guys walk away
and they think you know they're going to
be content without the the game that you
know really sustained them and brought
them so much joy
i i that is going to be him i mean
remember ray thompson wrote that great
article michael jordan years ago where
jordan's watching lebron james on tv and
talking about how he would defend him
knowing that he could if he just were a
little bit younger if not for time and
tom's going to tune in and watch
quarterbacks and know that he could do
this better and
you know
when that goes away i don't know i
remember
i was with elway and you and i talked
about it um
he was already right after they won the
super bowl when he was the general
manager
i think he was 55 at the time and he
said to me flat out like up until a
couple of years ago i thought i could
still play
and you know that that itch that
compulsion that desire never goes away
and
i don't know what brady's life looks
like without that i don't think he's
going to find as much joy
um talking about the game
you know would he ever be rich enough to
own a team i i you know that i i don't
know but either even so even being an
owner
um
you know
you have the highs and the lows but
you're not
it's close you're not part of the team
not in the locker room um
i think it's going to be a big
adjustment and it's something that he's
known about for a long time tried to
prepare for it's still going to be hard
though i think
so last one for you kind of waited to
finish up uh with this one again your
book seth wickersham it's better to be
field the new england patriots dynasty
in the pursuit of greatness is just one
of the best inside looks you can have to
dates for sure on the patriots and then
for any team uh in recent memory sir
so
what do you make of brady leaving the
patriots out of his
career retirement statement
you know i don't think it was an
accident at all i i still think that
there's some hard feelings over the way
that he left and the fact they opened
the door for him to leave and he walked
right out
but i think that he will find a way to
address
his full career
um
probably pretty soon you know who knows
maybe a video something like that but i
think that he'll figure out a way to
address it
and you know make it
very clear that you know he was a new
england patriot and that he cherishes a
lot of those memories yeah i mean
let's be honest i mean there was no
uglier exit
between all time great for a franchise
and franchise than farv and the packers
it couldn't have been uglier right
i mean where where the successor was
drafted and waiting and all that i mean
i don't need to re
re-litigate if you will but it was ugly
and far from the and the packers are all
cool right now so i'm not concerned
about all that but what what is it like
i thought brady and belichick had a a
chat and a confab after the week four
uh game that put this stuff to bed or
came close did it not then did it well i
think that
brady is always going to love bill
belichick for the chance that he gave
him and how invested he wasn't him um
but
you know the patriots made an
organizational decision that they didn't
think he could play
another two years you know they want to
keep it year by year at a lower you know
cap number
and you know after all that he had
accomplished
he was ready to go and look what he did
i mean he threw over 5000 yards this
year i think that including the playoffs
he must have come close to 100 touchdown
passes in two years in tampa it's just
phenomenal how good he was how good he
is
and
it's just as mind-boggling as his entire
career is it's just as mind-boggling
that he's walking away having
accomplished
you know coming off the season that he
had no doubt
no doubt but i mean and not to turn this
into a debate show but uh this kind of
is an interesting subject matter and you
are an expert at it for sure
um but
i mean
earlier on in this conversation you were
even saying part of the consideration of
no longer playing now
is the roster and things are being
remade i mean like he went he turned
he he turned nikhil harry into mike
evans you know what i mean like let's be
honest i mean part of the reason why he
left new england is because it was not a
tenable spot in which to win a
championship in 2020 which he did you
know gronk wasn't going to be coming
back through that door in new england
but did in tampa i mean it all worked
out you know what i'm saying so to leave
new england out entirely
from a statement where he's thanking
staffers for the bucks it's
it's kind of a head scratcher i'll be
honest unless there is so much water
underneath this bridge still
and you're saying there pretty much
still is
i mean i think that i think that the
fact that he did it i'd like i said i
just i don't think it was an accident um
you know but it'll be it's also be
interesting to see where he lives you
know does he decide to live in miami
they're building a house in miami and
you know in a year
this his old friend stephen ross old
michigan guy
brady on his instagram story
uh kind of like quote saved the bob
craft statement and then did a thank you
patriots and patriots nation with two
hearts there you go
all right so so in other words the
patriots are not like the instagram
story
so so basically we have we this is a
21st century thing certainly for a 44
year old man that's retiring uh
the honorable men so so basically
the patriots are not instagram
feed worthy
but instagram story but instagram
stories are shareable in the way that
the feed
is not right
so where do we like do we is does a tick
tock break the tie or what does that
mean i'm just also thinking about the
effort tom had to go to he would have
had to screenshot the patriots statement
then put it into a story and then type
out some text i mean
[Laughter]
but literally like that's what i i i i
that one left out at me and then uh the
fact that the word retirement wasn't in
there either it's just like you know
again an f you to father time i'm not
gonna even use that word
in my walk away statement you know what
i'm saying like i dug that one too that
one i caught my eye on that seth thanks
for the time man always appreciate the
two cents that you and uh that you are
willing to provide here thanks again my
pleasure man thank you you bet take care
uh seth wickersham i follow him on
twitter you should as well at seth
wickersham on instagram i mean on
twitter uh and uh it's better to be
feared where all books are sold what a
great book this is yes everything inside
writes you must read okay so um right
here on the rich eisens show